Welcome.
[inaudible].
This way. Yeah.
Lee come to Bay after nesting in Mona's bill
tour solo for the
[inaudible] [inaudible] uh, my husband.
[Inaudible].
The immaculate folk,
a mayor of Maxim poll at lever court
at, um, at lever, uh,
squabbling, sweat men. They had to that's on liver Alto.
[inaudible] Oh, Dubai 4k Kamia cloud.
They know as soon as they prostitute,
they got at sitting in a ER in Swansea.
Yeah. At the end. All the cell, the cell. Uh
[inaudible].
Yeah.
[inaudible] negative. Who's I mean more for ma yeah.
They were not have a [inaudible] just bought
in. Yeah. After
[inaudible] if a million [inaudible] so say I'm on schedule
[inaudible] there's going to be more durable.
So say yeah. When this gig, no,
I go lances and associate now. Okay.
[inaudible] associate. Yeah, my neck. No.
Okay. You haven't bothered the, then the
[inaudible] are they the first year? I think take a book. Okay. Yeah. Yeah.
Blurry. Bang. I wasn't afraid, uh, many, I think
[inaudible] you got to get going. You have to do things, you know?
So did they attend uh
[inaudible] Oh, Muskie school [inaudible] but said please Pope.
They live the har
[inaudible] the half a community care. My fault point. Only more Ms.
[inaudible]. Oh yeah. The communication.
[Inaudible] yeah. [inaudible].
Thanks for the [inaudible] or no, thank I.
Yeah. Normally either men, men medicate the
[inaudible] [inaudible] begin. Terry's more thing gay for of
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] so how much [inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] plus [inaudible].
Yeah. Yeah. I think product or your hospital
or [inaudible] uh, ed in men, men.
Did he ever had, uh, at mean ask
[inaudible], uh,
even as a sir or storm? Um
[inaudible] um, so you haven't said ping just to mean certain black to
told him, sir. So Hancock snagging,
mom, day on Hannah. Hannah. Okay. Muddy at 10 do there.
[inaudible] here, here, here.
[inaudible] data. [inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible].
Yeah. Now we know. Yes. Historian.
Uh,
he didn't come after me Morris to if the hints a big
thing. Um, add some
[inaudible] um, then that, um, normally Historia again,
Kenya or sovereign a non-New Historia, minnows, easy story or some,
yeah, Ken Kent, violet analyst. The comment of him for talent.
I mean more so as soon as the veins are sent, uh, yeah. May not hook
lamina our mayor in sampling a fertilizer in a
factor. So yeah, as soon as [inaudible],
but then there were little skillets, uh, he forgive him for
[inaudible] for [inaudible] glimpse them
[inaudible] so TVA didn't Dingo, Historia, the cuvette in go field.
So yeah, the garden. Does Claire falling someday.
And then, then, uh, you put
[inaudible] and Papa, uh, some,
uh [inaudible] uh, or they are, they are, how do you also help?
[inaudible] are there you dive extra? Um,
[inaudible].
Yeah. Oh yeah.
Fan do that then test Mankiller we'll make a C on Manheim Moolah.
Her thought it, um, you gain on Ireland. Uh,
also
[inaudible] dementia. Alzheimer's there's no, uh, no, I do. How do
[inaudible] [inaudible] so, yeah, [inaudible] uh, blood test.
Oh, DISA and I the
toy two 40. So the okay. [inaudible] uh, now yeah,
you have to, yeah,
I'll play the mince poses. And uh,
my in tint may, well, I more I'm in far
[inaudible] or man familiar middle of my book, bully, Denmark or USA. So
[inaudible] as a shoot. Um [inaudible] Oh, um,
scabber Willis. So Madden gun, man. Some spill. I mean far,
if he can, Oh. Hands for her to, to have so,
uh, or ask for a million. So they add my man, Ms. Coda. Yeah.
[Inaudible].
No men have their tempo up
past them. So,
so come in and see at the miss them,
the passer demons Gardez through
[inaudible] [inaudible] on dementia. Alzheimer's so nomad visa.
It means [inaudible] confused. Oh,
obviously these, uh, the issue cause soon spont. So
[inaudible] confused or this take me not blazer. So yeah.
Pour this in biller or, uh,
or, or schools Baylon um,
Hansen's pumped or Willis egg for the, they, them,
the passer on the uncertain
[inaudible] [inaudible] the demon in file tests and make a go. No, man.
[inaudible] the hard demands at Colby gear them.
You want to correct them for example,
[inaudible] snack on. It means [inaudible].
So do do,
do [inaudible] can see NIFA,
Johnny. Uh
[inaudible] well, there's two girls. So dura Johnny,
again for them are there for fat lead. It's terrible
also. So this, the, uh,
[inaudible] in gang men, so then they feel really stupid. They hear bike,
then pool them added DVL take them
data, sell duvet had been far in more Latin best event.
Some diva for the Scag to [inaudible].
Did I hear, or for example of this, this, this mean far hassock
[inaudible] more on math at a focused mud. Johnny
[inaudible] so CAA NA perfect.
ESPs are smart. They got over that and Harjani de
[inaudible]. So disclude masquerade called.
Uh, the investigative is, uh, possibly legal
[inaudible] [inaudible] sport.
[Inaudible] [inaudible] the, uh, can I get off the system? Yeah,
[inaudible] say
[inaudible] [inaudible] at the,
where I'll turn the menthol farming for shop in
spirit to would aggregate or
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] them men
[inaudible] and if you screwed it up
[inaudible] mentor. Yeah.
Do you do identify some
[inaudible] and [inaudible] couldn't have divided that photo.
Yeah.
Yeah. Hi
[inaudible] or Paul Gordon are there certain in Finn there feel,
uh, [inaudible] also I'm in fast.
I'm the tour. If the, um,
uh, men, men, men cars. Yeah. The, that, uh,
some stats mean Eastern Sierra.
I disrupt 90 spur all day and it's just coming back quick.
[inaudible] historian I'm in far hands and sport in Ghana and blue.
Then I see no hand boy USA
[inaudible] or not ment tele vehic dance
Mim in LA at the avail snack on another,
some vague hat on to her that I all the work.
So I had blue Timmins.
So we're going to have an attack, Danske Hinton, uh,
some men magically axon. So man, knock,
uh, half. Uh, so man,
I bought nine bowl in old man and I buying
[inaudible]. Uh
[inaudible] [inaudible] also say on putting it.
I don't understand what he's saying. He's talking that language again.
Can you ask him what he wants? I said, okay.
But if a VK glad the gambler stole his
name, I say to the, to the nurse. It's okay.
It's not important now. I'll I can deal with it. Add it on for, I saw
[inaudible] they, they got
[inaudible] [inaudible] use tops. Tessio
[inaudible] until far
for Austin.
[inaudible] used [inaudible] service yet. They have a fault.
[inaudible] lying eyes on
[inaudible] I just go ahead and just to make haste alone to assess your own also
CFR. Okay. Yeah. Comma [inaudible]. So geeky, Kirchner the effect man,
cop calf, or with
[inaudible] I attend in hand glimpse. It
[inaudible] again. So yeah. Gigging to, to harm
[inaudible] lesser associate. Yeah.
I handed them Mandela satisfied for the long too.
So Diego is saying [inaudible] men.
We say, we say two more iron man. He'll okay. My feet.
That's what I mean this year has that, that exists.
[inaudible] so
[inaudible] I must give a quick.
Nico. Uh, do, do VOC stop. Uh, they're spending they're spending,
uh, their CSR, uh, is cert America.
[inaudible] [inaudible] Madrid and
[inaudible] yeah.
Our two, yeah. Twice elements go through loss. I
[inaudible] at a
[inaudible] boy inland spoon [inaudible] so they, uh,
some, some men's guarded men. They are layered a high some, uh,
immediately, uh, uh,
D they may evicted for them to Hardy
Invoiceware to confer them or communicate them for
as the [inaudible].
So fairly high as specific, um,
uh, for hall till then, till Scandinavian.
Yeah. House before I'd say no.
Or you have a media that have to have all the Oslow, uh, uh,
[inaudible] on hours landscape. Um,
Oh yeah. For [inaudible] board,
the first tee or, I mean, you always, as a fairly, we have deferred,
uh, half a media. So Minda Munster. Well, yeah,
yeah. [inaudible] as the demo lead.
[Inaudible].
[Inaudible] or
[inaudible] [inaudible] some TD.
Yeah. They cut my input. I say, yeah.
[inaudible] no [inaudible] no, yes. Screw or dicked.
[inaudible] bill to come in and provide the handle on the,
go on non going at it.
[inaudible] for example, um, Magnolia Taylor,
Spence, Ella, you tell you it works,
uh, higher then cops ball as a yeah. Lead mass. And
[inaudible] last night. I wouldn't have taken four, man. Uh,
I'd be very anodized. No pretense men. They must get
[inaudible] men. Yo, yo America at,
at spoiler in the lit what Enya plus Antia ma
uh, Detroit is gonna play today.
[Inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] fantastic. Viggo, Beretta, Fred Viet,
the mere stories, uh,
[inaudible] live at full live. Uh,
[inaudible] dumb Manon. Uh, I mean, uh,
[inaudible] them, [inaudible] them.
[inaudible] [inaudible] your butt, your booty lender or your
[inaudible] and what? The young man with the Franklin
[inaudible] [inaudible] or
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]. Wow.
[inaudible] took them out for dog art to figure it out. And I loved it now.
Buddha, frankly care, like some
[inaudible] this horse on many core. I think
[inaudible] will do the, see a Monarch SWAT.
[inaudible] all of that secondary. It's all about human reaction.
More
[inaudible] made Medi-Cal so mere stories over there.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] or your soccer [inaudible] so let's see at
[inaudible] do you not think
[inaudible] [inaudible] so I'm your
[inaudible] [inaudible] mum. Buda Martin, man.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] man,
the persistent Factom
[inaudible] [inaudible] Corona post
[inaudible] [inaudible] splitters. Yeah, I'm familiar. Okay. Uh, or, or the,
we also build pole. There are some
[inaudible], uh,
[inaudible] diet promoted at least to build a poet at Lum.
Yeah. As a, yeah. It's toward in there Historia. I mean,
for me, Ian ball, Finn
care, mega scene spiraling as a
[inaudible] or falling Kevin [inaudible] for the
Daya conflict, uh, polo saying if a million,
some spider lit, but a skier, you Simon for no USA a minute.
Cornea was a, as there are no,
the COVID 19 pending me,
mendacity in Nan's slacks pending me. So may I start gambling?
Some, some men's got out. I did in
[inaudible]. So I'm there stay in. No,
I didn't do poorly community consumes and they meet,
uh, the bad communication pandemic that's happening now.
It's just as high up a problem. And it's not just the United States.
It's in Europe.
You have people who feel free now to be openly
racist and misogynist and intolerant.
And you know, of course this example is set by,
by our leaders often, you know, and, uh,
they give people permission to behave this way problem, uh,
at eager communicator. So God also fully come and say for fall.
And so I'm feeling, or some Linda ma my data scale USA,
your in for loss, uh, declared the cloud.
[inaudible] Lisa. So me film and logistics in the movie.
Yeah. Horrible at Mina, you know, memories, um,
um,
familiar ban as a connections, family connections,
the memory of a time when we could connect
might help us to reconnect. Now,
this is what happens in the story with the family. And I think in society,
whether it's the United States or Norway or Denmark or Ethiopia,
or anywhere when people remember,
um, you know, any country, Argentina, Somalia, anywhere, anywhere,
it doesn't matter if people together make an
effort to remember moments in their society's history,
when there was a good communication and some give and take. Yeah.
Then they can reestablish that again. I'm optimistic in that way.
Uh, yeah. Toward a more leads Alto. Uh, [inaudible] falling.
The handler must come in far on certain or certain,
uh, Myers. He's very stubborn. Uh,
and they'll communicate they're missing far.
[inaudible] [inaudible] are they more lit?
It's possible that even if you are just as stubborn about communicating as the
other person is stubborn about not communicating,
maybe you will never have a point of contact.
Maybe you will not find compassion and empathy,
but it's possible. If you say, forget it,
the relationship is over. I'm not talking to you anymore.
Then there is no hope for progress. The same with different countries,
different races, different religions. If you stop talking, then nothing happens.
They say got, so they hadn't been there for my
[inaudible].
[Inaudible], um, uh, [inaudible] festivals,
uh, achievement award, uh, Noah, uh,
[inaudible] uh, fantastic.
[inaudible] uh, [inaudible] Peter Jackson's
[inaudible] [inaudible].
They are loud, uh,
analysts and they,
so did you have four torching eating, some add them the,
uh, Delto you didn't feel clear loggy by the FIC
FLIR Molitor for Finn Arba, uh, go all, uh, you know,
good parts, good opportunities. I mean,
the victory is to layout VAR at,
you know, to solve problems. You know,
it was a long shoot and Peter Jackson had a crew of maybe
700 people.
Most of them from New Zealand who had very little experience in making
movies, many of them and no experience in making a huge movie like that one.
So they learn [inaudible] or revise
[inaudible] and two they're not malaria and film or,
and Peter Jackson was, was amazing in his patients.
And he always working collectively with people,
found ways to solve all kinds of problems,
even if he had to invent a completely new way of filming something. Well,
it can be done. We'll figure out a way.
So it was just that there's always a solution and you don't have to
do it by yourself. In fact, it's always better if you do it as a team,
you know? So did they allowed a mist on Firefox
Peter Jackson or then fin.
[Inaudible].
Uh, yeah. Here for contour [inaudible] toy.
Knock the pleasing to me in a, for stock on finfish
then. Uh, yeah. [inaudible] so, I mean, Darla
[inaudible] has not been demo their tone 10 guy yet. Uh
[inaudible] for [inaudible] flu. You just cannot wear
[inaudible].
[Inaudible].
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean the daily for Kenyans, uh, they are
[inaudible] on. So thirdly, I'm a veteran in that sense. So the
[inaudible] a beginner first time director, but on the other end,
I'm getting this prize, which I don't know if it's a hint to say, okay,
you're done making brother.
But.
I'm not done. I'm stubbornly going to keep going.
[Inaudible] hope you enjoyed the clip for more interesting conversations,
please hit subscribe.